انتهى فرز الاصوات في الانتخابات التركيه
التي وصفت بالمصيريه دون ان تحدد مصير
البلاد
[موسيقى]
قالت هذه الصناديق كلمتها فمنح التحالف
الجمهور الذي يقوده حزب العداله والتنميه
الحاكم فوزا مريحا في البرلمان لكنها لم
تحسم فوز زعيم الحزب الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
بالرغم من تقدمه بفارق كبير عن منافسه
مرشح المعارضه كما الكليج دارول
وفقا للقانون الانتخابي لم يفز اي من
المرشحين في الانتخابات الرئاسيه وعليه
قررنا عقد جوله ثانيه يوم الثامن والعشرين
من مايو الجاري الصحف المقربه من الحكومه
رات ان اراده الشعب تجلت في هذه النتائج
عندما منحت اردوغان اصواتا بفارق وصل الى
نحو مليونين ونصف مليون صوت عن منافسه
بينما رات صحف المعارضه ان الرجل خسر هذه
الانتخابات بل وات الحكومه بمحاوله
التلاعب في النتائج لكن يبقى ان عوامل عده
حرمت اردوغان الفوز من الجوله الاولى في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه وافقدته اسطنبول
والعاصمه انقره اكبر المدن التركيه وهو
الذي لطالما حصل على النسبه الاكبر من
اصوات المدينتين
الاقتصاد والزلزال في تركيا اضرار الحكومه
بشكل كبير لكن جهودها الكبيره في دعم
المتضررين من الزلزال اقنعتهم بالتصويت
بشكل كبير لتحالف الجمهور اما الغلاء
والتضخم وخصوصا في المدن الكبرى فجعلا
كثيرا من الناخبين وخصوصا الشباب يفضلون
البديل
[موسيقى]
اكثر من خمسه في المئه حصل عليها المرشح
القومي سنان اوران في هذه الانتخابات لا
شك انها ستلعب الدوره الحاسمه في تحديد
نتيجه الجوله الثانيه الامر الذي يرى فيه
كثير من المراقبين ان مزيجا من الناخبين
القوميين ومن العلمانيين الغاضبين من
انسحاب مرشحهم محرم انجاح بشكل مفاجئ قبل
عده ايام من الانتخابات سيكون رمانه
القبان في هذه الجوله يقول حزب العداله
والتنميه انه حقق انتصاره السادس عشر على
التوالي في تاريخه لكنه يبدو انتصارا
منقوصا هذه المره سيقود الحزب الى مواجهه
جديده محتدمه ستتداخل فيها عوامل خارجيه
وداخليه عده قبل ان يحسم الاسم الذي سيقود
البلاد خلال السنوات الخمس المقبله امرنا
في الجزيره اسطنبول